that'd be cool to have the demons powers
the first part
yeah that was fun
yeah
deemed the demon's an [ __ ] man yeah
it's like i'm gonna let you have fun
with this for a while then i'm gonna
take it all away from me totally dick
this demon's a douche
hey what's up fool my name is ryan
wright and like my name is jerry dude
welcome to reasons to csa we're gonna
like give you some reasons to see and
maybe not the [ __ ] see like
paranormal activity the marked ones so
let's chill
and smoke a joint because that's what
that's what they do right
i think there might be like one smoking
see there's one smoking scene yeah
except we're
reason to see number one
it's kind of fresh
so we saw a paranormal activity the
marked ones the all-latino cast in this
spin-off of paranormal activity
the franchise yeah you know it takes
place in the paranormal activity
universe yeah but this time we're in
oxnard california and it's minorly
linked to
katie featherson honestly i i thought
this was going to be a big pile of [ __ ]
i really enjoyed this movie yeah i had a
lot of fun i i was like
they're spinning it off they're pushing
it to january i don't know
and then it ended up being like a total
delight like the story was pretty cool i
like the way how everything kind of kind
of unfolded kind of had that chronicle
thing about it for a little bit yeah a
little bit you know i feel like this
demon gives this guy super powers for
some reason one interestingly enough
like i think making it you know an
all-hispanic cast and making it take
place in that kind of a community is a
really cool idea because it's a very
religious community anyway so you get
that side of you know there's there's
something that's always like really
creepy about
older spanish women praying it was if
you don't speak spanish and you just
hear them talking spanish it's like oh
my god some voodoo shit's going on yeah
it actually felt very fresh you know i
was surprised i was so used to these
paranormal movies being like you've been
here done that and i really feel like
this is i'm enjoying this story i
especially like the cast a lot the cast
was fantastic that's very natural yeah
very natural and uh like the two main
guys in the film i like the buddy not
the main guy jesse who's getting
possessed i like the buddy a lot um he
was hilarious
it's funny like
yeah funny moments yeah you know their
banter and their back and forth and
stuff makes their relationship really
believable and it's really fun to watch
these two dudes hang out for a while and
do stupid [ __ ] until bad things start to
happen yeah you know and it's kind of
nice to have somebody at least as scared
as you should be you know behind the
camera well that was one of the things
about the bad things that start to
happen because the first like half of
this movie is really fun you know
there's a lot of humor in it and then
the last half gets like super [ __ ]
serious and i think the paranormals tend
to do that i thought it actually took
away from the film in this one oh i
disagree i mean i thought i thought the
transition was really natural
all i gotta say is [ __ ] you
if you want
okay let's turn off the camera and do
this reason to see number two
the cast
yeah i thought it was really interesting
to set it uh with these types of
characters too because it's very
different than
white people watching this one versus
some of the other ones it was a lot
easier to get just acclimated to the
style and the characters and everything
that's going on so it's not as i don't
the the previous ones don't exactly hold
you at arm's length but there's
something that's a little harder to
really feel for the people yeah you know
involved and this one i thought you know
because these guys are so sort of
regular makes it you know that much more
engrossing yeah the writing of it they
made them really likable you kind of
know how it's going to end because they
all sort of end the same way i mean you
know you know what this movie is going
to be it's that same thing it's like
it's not new but it does it well reason
is see number three
has fun scares
and uh there's some scary [ __ ] yeah
that's what you all want to know about
right
there's uh there's some scary stuff i
wasn't this was the least scared i've
been during a paranormal movie excluding
part four you know there's fun skaters
in it a lot of jump scares i was a
little bit distracted though when these
scares and were like really effects
heavy that's what i loved about the
first paranormal was like oh it's so
grounded in such a type of reality and
this one
sometimes it was like well they're
obviously using effects for that you
know so it would distract me and pull me
out a little bit because everything else
is so naturalistic it's like when there
is cg thrown in there it's glaring and
also this movie does not fix why are you
filming syndrome for some reason i guess
it was just like the characters or what
was going on but for some reason i
wasn't as distracted by it this time
yeah
every once in a while i was like why why
are you filming i was thinking yeah yeah
i was sitting there it would cross my
mind every now and again but the rest of
the movie worked enough for me that i
wasn't going seriously there were
moments in paranormal activity too and
any of the other ones really where i was
like why do you have a camera right now
yes it's a latino cast but they didn't
just like cast latinos it's like
straight up like oxnard california type
of people you know people are from the
ghetto
it's [ __ ] awesome they deal with
thugs and stuff it's pretty [ __ ] cool
man it's like a paranormal movie that
takes place in the hood part of what
makes this movie work is is that it's
not all confined to one house which
really does help yeah you know that's
true yeah because because uh the other
ones are just in one house and this one
it's like it goes with you everywhere it
goes like this is this is showing the
process all over town again doesn't help
the whole why are you still filming
thing but it does help to make the story
go more places there's nothing like
super fresh or new this movie doesn't
reinvent the wheel as people would like
to say but it does roll it well in terms
of the the scares and the chills and
stuff it's not there's nothing that's
gonna make you go home and be like oh my
god oh yeah absolutely not but there are
some fun and effective jumps and stuff
you can tell there's some energy going
on you know behind the camera and i
thought the demon even though you
obviously don't see the demon but i
thought the demon had a personality to
it yeah it's like you kind of got you
like children's games yeah he does like
children's games ryan's consensus a
movie that you thought would be shitty
but isn't is the reason to see
paranormal activity the marked ones a
movie that you thought would be shitty
but wasn't is the reason to see
paranormal activity the marked ones yeah
i really enjoy this i liked it more than
part four that's
i guess i'm looking forward to this new
franchise more latinos just recording it
worked out you know
i think just one is okay the one thing
about all the people they haunt they're
all connected by they all love to record
everything that's happening i mean all
the other paranormal activity movies are
like vaguely connected and then oh look
it's katie yeah you know like that's the
through line so you know it's just yeah
it's just different because it's not
white people in the summers jerry's
consensus a fun found footage throw ride
is the reason to see paranormal activity
the march ones a fun found footage
thrill ride is the reason to see
paranormal activity the marked ones yeah
like i said before you know it's a good
time there's some some effective jumps
it's it's exactly what you expect it's
gonna be but it's it does it well all
right guys let's check in our view for
paranormal activity the marked ones why
don't you go ahead scroll that comment
box below and tell us which one is your
favorite paranormal activity film once
you're done with that come on over here
click this button so you can see more
episodes of reasons to see and once
you're done watching all of our episodes
of reasons to see i'm sure you want to
get updated every time another episode
of reason c is out so in that situation
what you're going to want to do is the
next thing that i'm about to say which
is this subscribe
all right
yeah i like to build things up if it's
not my favorite it might be up there
in terms of paranormal activity for me
my favorites go
paranormal 2 the one that no one [ __ ]
likes
paranormal one
paranormal activity the marked ones no
paranormal three and paranormal the
marked ones
like i think those four are good films
yeah there's a shitty number four film
that's just awful that made you lose all
faith in the franchise it's just a
really horrible experience
yeah i mean
i actually four was the one i missed
but out of
it's like three and this one are
actually sort of grappling for my
favorite just in terms of watchability
two is is uneven but i like it still
dude too is so scary to me really don't
you remember what she's sitting
in the kitchen and then everything just
[ __ ] opens that's the only scare i
remember
what about when she was being dragged
i thought that was a cool effect you
weren't scared my jaw was dropped the
entire time i don't recall i was pretty
terrible i was more scared during two
than i was during one
and then three than two like and the
ending of part two was
brilliant kind of i got distracted by
the way she snapped that dude's neck
that's what distracted you i got to
start because it didn't look real to me
you didn't think it was cool how they
tied it in with katie like that and
where she went after part one yeah i
thought it was all right dude it was
[ __ ] awesome i thought it was cool it
didn't like blow my mind it blew my mind
and everyone else yeah i think this one
blew my mind a little bit more really
yeah
why
because it like bent space time that's
true oh that'd be cool paranormal starts
dealing with space-time continuum stuff
maybe that's what they're building up to
maybe
you know how like fast and the furious
was like a car racing movie now it's
like all heist films yeah that's kind of
what they're probably going to do with
this they're going to make it time
traveling horror flicks
who knows i mean that's you know i could
see some kind of evolution coming in
there i could see that too that would be
cool they like time travel back to when
the demon was walking the earth
no yeah so they could kill the demon
head-on with their video camera with
their video camera because they gotta
just it's not like they're saying how to
document this yeah there's a lot of
moments where i was like you wouldn't be
recording right now yeah you would just
be running away your your cinematography
skills would not be this good if that
[ __ ] was really happening yeah he's like
running and the camera is just like
still on it's like he's running and
looking through the lens yeah exactly
you